have a better together campaign
the coveted 19 pandemic has changed our
world
in ways we could never have imagined
when it started just over a year ago
beyond the deaths and diseases caused by
the virus itself
health systems have been disrupted
millions of
jobs have been lost schools have been
closed
poverty and hunger have been exacerbated
and the global economy has been thrown
into turmoil every part of society has
been affected
and so every part of society must be
part of the response
and the recovery over the next 40
minutes
leaders from politics business
and entertainment will explain why
they're supporting
global citizens recover better together
campaign first
it's my honor to introduce the president
of the european commission
her excellency dr ursula fonder lane
your excellency thank you for your
support for wh
over the past year especially in
launching the access to covet
19 tools accelerator thank you for
joining us today
you have the flow
thank you very much dr tedros and dear
friends of global citizen
indeed last year who the european union
and global citizen teamed up to fight
coronavirus
and many many others joined us it was an
amazing and inspiring experience
and indeed together we achieved a lot we
created the act accelerator and covax
the global facility to deliver
affordable and
equitable vaccines to the world this was
a big success
but let's be frank much more is needed
first more funding is needed and that's
why as team europe
we increased our contribution to covax
last week
bringing it to around 2.2 billion euros
and second vaccine doses are needed
now vaccines are still scarce
everywhere but it is in our
common interest to share and i therefore
fully support president macron's
proposal
to donate vaccine doses that are
necessary to vaccinate healthcare
workers in africa
vaccines must reach all corners of the
planet
as soon as possible in fact
europe is the continent that exports the
most vaccines to the rest of the world
we try
hard to walk the talk
but everybody needs to chip in and it is
not only about vaccination
the crisis is bigger than that and this
is why
i'm proud to support the new global
citizen campaign
a recovery plan for the world let's
overcome the pandemic with a global
vaccination campaign
let's stop the hunger crisis bring
children back to their classrooms
fight rising inequalities and engage in
a green recovery
treating our planet with care and
respect
yes we have to fight the pandemic right
now but we are also have to address
its broader impact on the most
vulnerable
and we need to tackle the root causes
the first important renew of the year
will be the global health summit in may
which i will convene with prime minister
draghi in rome
it will be a moment to reflect on the
lessons learned
but also to agree on a common
preparedness blueprint so that the world
is never again
caught off guard all must weigh in
governments and international
organizations
scientists businesses and civil society
philanthropic foundations and private
citizens
everyone needs to contribute
global citizen has already demonstrated
that engaged and committed citizens can
move mountains you
you have a unique gift to convene people
let's do it again as one world
reunited
thank you thank you so much president
vanderloin and
support of team europe has been so
important
in the past year and we look forward to
our continued partnership
again thank you so much for your
leadership
now it's my great pleasure to introduce
the chief executive officer of global
citizen
hugh evans hugh thank you for everything
global citizen has done over the past
year
including our collaboration on the
together at home concert
which raised